it's important to note that the research
you conduct with your prototype doesn't
have to be complicated but it does have
to be effective to be effective your
research needs to answer whatever
questions you asked in the beginning
this was a great insight shared by tomor
schron in the product design course so
what questions are those the stage or
fidelity your prototype is in will
determine the type of feedback you ask
for and the type of questions you ask
first it's easier to get good
information from qualitative questions
rather than quantitative questions for
example if you're presenting a low
fidelity prototype you're probably just
going to want to ask very high-level
questions such as can a user easily
learn and use this app however if you're
presenting a prototype that includes
micro interactions and is reflective of
the finished product you'll probably
want to ask questions such as how does
this animation feel to you do the
interactions get in the way of or
improve the experience your goals are
entirely different at that stage since
you're moving to more of a finished
product I've put a list of useful
questions to ask and answer for each
kind of prototype in the instructor
notes below the video these questions
will get you feedback valuable feedback
is any feedback that combines a specific
part of the prototype with a positive or
negative feeling on the part of the user
for instance a user reporting they are
confused by the menu is very valuable
feedback as as user being excited how
quickly they could achieve their goal
specific suggestions can be helpful
feedback but are often not useful until
you're working on very high fidelity
prototypes when you're first recording
users feedback make sure to keep all of
it that you can we'll talk later on
about how to go about doing this and
about what permission you need from your
users at the end of lesson you'll be
looking for patterns in the feedback
from various users on the same prototype
so detailed records are vital